الطريق إلى إيفانيفكا ليس مستهترًا آمنًا ،
اسمه الحربي يأخذنا إلى هناك عبر
البلاد ، يقول إن قواته استعادت السيطرة عليها
من الروس بعد معركة بالمدفعية استمرت أسبوعين ، كان
الهجوم الثاني
بالأقدام قبل شهر لا يزال مهجورًا
فقط الحيوانات الأليفة المهجورة  وحيوانات المزرعة
هنا الآن
عندما تأتي إلى هنا وتنظر
إلى المزرعة هنا ، الحيوانات التي تركت
الكلب في حالة رهيبة ، كيف تشعر
بالحزن الشديد ومتى يمكن للناس العودة
إلى هذه القرية أه أعتقد
عندما نكون  سوف
نتقدم أكثر
إلى السطر التالي للقرى التي
لم تنفجر القذائف تتناثر على الأرض
نهاية الحرب بعيدًا. يقول
أعتقد أنه ليس
أه سننتهي سريعًا جدًا
لأن أه
لسنا أقوياء الآن
أثناء الهجوم  هنا تقدر القوات الأوكرانية
أنها قتلت حوالي 50
جنديًا روسيًا وأصيب حوالي مائة آخرين ،
وهو التحدي الكبير الذي يواجه الأوكرانيون الآن
عددًا كافيًا من الرجال للتقدم
في خط المواجهة على بعد
بضعة كيلومترات فقط.  ضربت قذيفة مدفعية
هدفها ، وقد تحركت القوات التي استولت على إيفانيفكا
الشهر الماضي ،
ونحن نخطط للمضي قدمًا بالتأكيد
عندما
لا أعرف من رأيي الخاص ، أعتقد أن
[الموسيقى]
في غضون شهر
عند نوافذ مدرسة القرية حطمت
الفصول الدراسية ودمرت الحصص الفارغة  حزم
على الأرض ورسالة مكتوبة قبل
انسحابهم ، تركت القوات الروسية
رسالة فراق تقول إن روسيا موجودة في
كل مكان ليس لها حدود ،
وهنا قاموا بشطب الكلمة الأوكرانية
للمسيرة وقالوا استخدموا اللغة الصحيحة
حيث الروس  بدا وكأنه يقاتل
خنادق خط المواجهة بقوة بالقرب من
عربات القرية المدرعة والدبابات التي
أخرجتها المدفعية ،
تحصل على فكرة عن ضراوة
القتال هنا من
تأثيرات المدفعية والطريقة التي تم بها تمزيق الأشجار هنا
ولكن إليك مفاجأة تصيب هذه
الأهداف  مع المدفعية الأمريكية الموهوبة m Triple Seven ،
لم يكن الأمر سهلاً كما توقع الجنود ،
فأنا أقوم برمي الثلاثي السابع
بشكل جيد جدًا ،
لكن
الآن الآن جيد جدًا كما توقعنا  ليس تيد جاكراً
للجميل كما يقول ومستعد
جداً لتعلم مهارات أفضل
نيك روبرتسون cnn evanevka أوكرانيا